- It's the holidays friends.
So to celebrate, here's
some of our favorite
new and returning TV and streaming picks
that are sure to put you
in the spirit of the season
on this week's Binge Guide.
Oh, the holidays.
It's time for cozy clothes,
face fulls of food,
and lots and lots of movie and TV shows
for your annual holiday Binge.
And although there are tons
of classic holiday options,
we think that these brand new titles
are sure to bring you
some much needed cheer
this holiday season.
So, in no particular
order, here are our picks
for the best new holiday themed shows
and streaming movies of the year,
starting with the new Hulu
film, "Happiest Season."
This heartfelt and hilarious
rom-com stars, Kristen Stewart
and Mackenzie Davis, as her girlfriend,
who has yet to come out to her parents,
who the two visit for Christmas.
And with tons of heartfelt moments,
it adds a much needed queer-take
on the traditional home
for the holidays storyline.
Critics have called the film quote,
"An utter delight with more
than enough holiday cheer
"that should be added to the list
"of holiday season staples."
You can watch this one in
just an hour and 42 minutes,
but it'll leave a smile
on your face for days.
And next on our list is
the Netflix family film,
"Jingle Jangle: A Christmas Journey".
Keegan-Michael Key and
Forest Whitaker star
in this musical fantasy about
a down on his luck toy maker
who gets back in the groove
with the help of his granddaughter
and lots of song and dance.
The film redefines what a
Christmas musical can be.
With nine original songs
including one written
by Grammy winner, John Legend,
critics say "Jingle Jangle"
is a holiday adventure
with an uplifting message
that celebrates the yule-tide season.
And at just two hours long,
you could just put this one
on repeat and you'll have yourself
a merry little Christmas soundtrack.
Another holiday must
binge is the new series,
"Dash and Lily".
This Netflix series seems
like typical young adult fare
with beautiful well-to-do
older teens running
around New York city in winter,
but don't judge the red
note book by its cover.
Look closer and you'll
find a charming show
filled to the brim with holiday cheer,
lovable characters, and
some great rom-com moments
that'll melt even the coldest of hearts.
At a perfect 100% on the tomato meter,
critics all agree that "Dash and Lily"
is a delightful rom-com adventure
with plenty of holiday cheer.
The whole season can be binged
in just under three 3 1/2 hours,
which makes it the perfect
jolt of Christmas spirit
for anyone who needs it.
And we're gonna throw a dose of reality TV
into the mix with our next pick,
"The Great Christmas Light Fight".
This feel-good competition
show first debuted in 2013
and aims to find the best,
brightest, and most awe-inspiring
Christmas light decorations
around the country.
From traditional snowmen and reindeer
to elaborate custom builds
with robots or pyrotechnics,
this show is sure to
inspire you and your family
with the contestants'
creativity and passion
for spreading holiday cheer.
And while we don't have a
critic's consensus for the show,
we can say that fans of cooking, crafting,
and home renovation shows will find plenty
to love on "Light Fight".
And with eight seasons, bingeing this show
will keep you busy for 45 hours,
but you'll have more than enough inspo
for your next light decoration project.
And last, but certainly not least is
"The Christmas Chronicles" Part Two".
Directed by a holiday movie
maestro, Christopher Columbus,
the Netflix film stars real-life couple,
Kurt Russell and Goldie Hawn
as Mr. and Mrs. Claus, which should be
all the recommendation
necessary, but the show backs up
the big names with big
heart, Christmas magic,
and classic holiday
sentimentality in spades.
Critics say "The Christmas
Chronicles: Part Two"
is more engaging than the first film,
and is a sweet second
helping of holiday cheer
that fans of the first
will certainly enjoy.
And while you could just stream part two
in about two hours, you
should start with part one
to get the full Christmas
Chronicles experience
which will take you an
extra hour and 45 minutes.
All right, friends, now you've
got plenty of titles to add
to your nice list and
maybe some new favorites
that you can come back to year after year.
For even more holiday TV and
streaming recommendations,
be sure to check out rottentomatoes.com.
And be sure to check out the
new Rotten Tomatoes Is Wrong,
a podcast from Rotten Tomatoes,
because fresh and rotten
is just the beginning of the conversation.
And new episodes drop every Thursday.
And we'll see you guys back here
for more recommendations based
around the movies and shows that you love
right here on the Rotten
Tomatoes Binge Guide.
(upbeat music)